receita secreta da internet OK ele vai
colocar folha de árvore dentro do buraco
não percebi Ui que é aquilo gengibre
esmagou já pegou com a colher ui ele vai
comer isto assim Ui é um mini balte é
mini comidas olha um bocadinho de arroz
ralado mais pão mais vinagre ele fez uma
farinha ui ele vai aquecer a panel que é
aquilo uma maçã uma mini maçã Ok descas
com a maçã Ah é um porzinho de batata
cebola alho Olha que bom
olha agora fiz um mini pãozinho oh que
bonitinho ó mini rolo oh que bonitinho
bem podre né que ele vai fazer pizza Ah
isto deve ser p de hambúrguer Aposto que
é p de hambúrguer olha olha olha já vai
fazer Ah não é panquecas Isto é o quê tá
a fritar as panquecas que horror
panqueca em
óleo não é batata não é pão Afinal Olha
esmagou o pão recheou o pão